[Music]
i'm back in your face
chuck well virtually yes
[Laughter]
just because you move closer to the
camera
[Laughter]
it's not as intimidating as it is in
real life and you're you're a pretty big
guy
so in real life that'd be intimidating
you know but
virtually it's just like you're you're
like making a funny face to me just
that's a you know when i grew up in the
street if people want to get in a fight
but if we're going to get into a fight
but you didn't want to fight the person
you pretend you were angry and then you
were badass but you'd say hold me back
right exactly and you run behind people
to have them hold your back
nobody's touching you dude what are you
talking about i said hold me back man
that's my
i'm telling you yeah yeah i need you to
hold me back right
so he don't hit me right so
what am i talking about i'm gonna talk
about earth okay okay
i like that place okay so good good so
how long does earth take to rotate on
its axis
from what i've been told 24 hours 24
hours okay
in fact we kind of defined 24 hours to
mean that
right so that's how you we divide up
time okay
so as you might have guessed it doesn't
take 24 hours um
it actually takes 23 hours 56 minutes
and four seconds
okay really yes
let me just be clear about what i mean
23 hours
get rid of the entire just get rid of
the entire solar system
okay and watch earth rotate okay and
stand there and time it
it will that spot that's in front of you
will come back around
in 23 hours 56 minutes and four seconds
one full revolution
okay okay that's called a sidereal day
a second i mean stars starting
however we don't base our lives
on when stars return to the same spot in
the sky
in the night sky we'd base our days on
when the sun
which also happens to be a star returns
to its spot on the sky
okay it turns out that takes longer
than 23 hours and 50. why i tell you why
because
in the time it took earth to rotate
23 hours and 56 minutes it actually
moved almost one degree in its orbit
around the sun
so it rotates back to where its previous
line but it has to turn a little bit
extra a little bit definitely to get
back to the same thing
a little bit extra to put the sun back
in the same spot on the sky right
and that's a little bit yeah one minutes
extra that's fantastic
and why didn't i say god that's
so so that little extra four minutes so
i said
we move a degree in our orbit each day
you know i didn't just
pull that out how many how many days are
there in a year uh
365 okay and how many degrees in a
circle
360. yeah so it's about a degree it's
about a day
a day yeah we to 10 is one degree and
five
360 sixty-fifths oh wow have a degree
but it's basically a degree a day and in
that degree you have to turn that little
extra
so just imagine you keep having to turn
your head just a little bit extra amount
okay because you're gonna move just a
little bit so now you gotta look back
just a little bit
correct cool well let's keep going okay
all right
earth's orbit around the sun is not a
perfect circle
oh boy by the way so the first day is a
sidereal day
the second day is a solar day that's
okay
so for obvious reasons and they don't
they're not the same all right now
earth's orbit around the sun is not a
perfect circle right
some which means sometimes we're farther
away sometimes we're closer
when we are closer we are moving faster
in our orbit
than when we are farther away okay
okay that's how gravity works
so it turns out that extra four minutes
is not the same if we're farther from
the sun than if we're closer to the sun
because we moved more than
our allocated fraction of a circle
when we're close to the sun and less
when we're farther away from the sun
that's it okay so
the length of the solar day is
changing continually throughout the year
wow
and sometimes it's less than 24 hours
sometimes it's more than 24 hours
so sometimes the sun gets to its highest
point in the sky
before clock noon right and sometimes it
gets
so what we do is we just average that
over the whole year and say son
you are average 24 hours and there you
go
wow by the way if you ever look at
sundials
there's a map on this sundial that
corrects for the sun being
early and the sun being late you either
add or subtract
up to 14 minutes of the day
from what the sun time reads in order to
get your clock time
wow all right every sundial has it so
it's a figure eight
it's called an analemma it's got a name
and a lemon but i don't want to talk
about analytics right now
so what you have on your clock is the
average length of a day
over the 365 days of the year all right
so now we define that as 24 hours
each hour 60 minutes each minute 60
seconds got it
okay well what is defining this well
it's the rotation of the earth
right okay makes sense well
well all right well how stable is that
even in the perfect average that we're
taking uh
it's house well you'll never know will
you because you're using earth to define
the
the time frame right exactly if earth
is your measure and you are slowing down
you will never know this just there's no
way to know it
right okay now back when i was growing
up
watches they would boast this is how old
i am they would say get this watch it's
so accurate it's accurate to two minutes
a month
okay what that that was like accurate
that is not
a good advertising okay but then it was
because
you know cheap watches were 10 minutes a
month you'd have to re you'd set your
watch every day
why do you think heist movies would
always say
let's synchronize our clocks right
before they played on the heist
that's cool they knew that the clocks
they were not keeping good time earth
was keeping the best time of them all
okay so now you pose
the question maybe earth is not the best
time heating device let's
offload the responsibility of keeping
time to something else
like a vibrating atom so we did that
so the ccm 137 there's a
electron transition between two energy
levels that has a very
precise frequency okay
very precise you can measure what's good
about that is any lab can get some ccm
and measure this
and then define the length of a second
in their lab okay
okay when you do this
you multiply it by 60 you multiply that
by 60 you get the hour you multiply that
by 24
you do you do this and you find out
that earth is slowing down
[Music]
well you know it's kind of old
i'm just insane it's been added
it's tired that's a lot of tired really
if you're four point six billion years
old you might slow down a little bit
you might be tired i'm just saying you
might lose a step on your own
that's very sweet of you that's very
it's very geriatrically
sensitive of you so you only would know
that earth was slowing down once you
offload it
to something else that tracks time right
and what we found out
is that the sloshing of tides
on the ocean floor on the beach fronts
actually works to
slow down the rotation of the earth
oh wow okay because the moon is causing
these tides
right okay and we're rotating faster
than the moon is orbiting us
so the moon is tugging on tides
backwards on our attempt to rotate right
okay so it's almost like there's a
a counter weight the counterbalance
exactly
that's pulling against what against us
so
tides are slowing down the rotation of
the earth and in response the moon
is spiraling away from us by a couple
inches a year
okay that's in response to earth slowing
down it all relates to what's called the
conservation of angular momentum but
it's a big ballet
okay and so we've been slowing down and
chuck
that's so we what we could do is say
let's redefine the second
the length of the second so that we
always have 24 hours and 60 minutes and
60 seconds
but that's messy every year here's a new
definition of the second
pope folks go to your lab redefine the
cesium atom it's much
easier to accept the fact that you know
we're breaking up with the moon but
you know it's just taking some time
breaking up is hard to do
everybody everybody has to be on the
same
page so the breakup can be as amicable
uh so that's
uh that that's that's a nice way to
think about it
so so this so we the way we compensate
for this
is how we add a leap second
when when do we oh well it has to be
every four years then we had a no no no
no
no no no did i mention years at all
dude days every four days no
no no no what i'm saying is we
monitor when we have fell behind a
second
okay so when the second when we know
that we've lost a second
based on our atomic measurement
correct then internationally we say time
to throw in a leap second now
by convention we throw it in on june
30th or on december 31st
and we can throw in one at each time if
we needed it okay
since 1973 or four or something like
early 70s
there's been 23 24 leap seconds
added to the calendar sweet so when
they're gonna add a leap second they
choose which of those days it will be
when they do so that final minute has 61
seconds in it nice
yes it's very cool that's very cool and
so
so this is what we do that's the largest
minute of
yes it's the longest minute because it's
actually 61 seconds
okay so newspapers like having fun with
they say this year will be slightly
longer than other years
right because you have to throw in the
leap second that leap second happens on
greenwich time so for us it would take
place at like
uh i guess 7 p.m right because we're
five hours
uh behind them when the christmas mean
so i was at a dinner party once in the
june 30th leap second
at 7 pm that's when you're having dinner
and i said pause
i got out the atomic clock and we just
watched that sucker tick
61 seconds went by we toasted it with a
sip of champagne
and then went on our way okay why are
you walking around with an atomic clock
no no i have wait just don't have access
don't just let's not
just i got people okay
right on it all right so a couple more
things
uh other things that can change the
rotation of the earth not just the title
swatching
right okay but here's one for you you
ready
good right you've seen skaters who uh
want to speed up their speed
so what do they do their hands start out
extended
and they start with a slight rotation
they bring in their hands and they spin
faster
right right what they've done is they
changed where the mass is
relative to their rotation axis right so
the farther away the mass is
the slower they're going to rotate the
closer it is to the rotation
the faster they'll turn right okay if
earth has an earthquake
and one of the continental slabs
shifts north okay
then there's mass on earth's surface
that used to be closer to the equator
the day before and has now moved closer
to the pole
that will have the effect of speeding up
the rotation of the earth right
large animals that migrate
okay will change where the mass
of the earth is from the northern climes
down to the south
and they're farther away from the
rotation of the axis
so not only does do tides affect the
rotation of the earth
my seasonal migration of animals affects
the rotation of the earth and so does
earthquakes
so do volcanoes and anything else that's
remapping
the surface of the earth you know what
else to change it the melting
of land glaciers uh-oh we're in trouble
okay that you got uh antarctica has
has land glaciers as it melts what used
to be right there near the pole
now melts and goes closer to the equator
that will
slow down the rotation of the earth
because that's like the skater
bringing their hands away right so all
of these factors combined
basically the earth's day has been
increasing rather than d
and principally could decrease depending
on what's going on
right did i i then i had this diabolical
idea we'd go set up jet engines
um anchor them to the earth face them
either due east or due west and ignite
them
and then the exhaust would help uh speed
up or slow down the earth i thought we
might do that then i did the math on
that
and no it's not going to work it's not
enough
you would have made a good bond villain
though
yeah it's just you know it's like lex
luthor saying let me
um create an earthquake to um
create trees from property in california
so yes geo engineering on
on a huge scale um but in principle you
could do that
but if you take the greatest engines and
fire them
the mass of the earth is so huge you
just haven't essentially no effect
no effect at all yeah so i'm just saying
the rotation rate of the earth is a
is is susceptible to all these small
effects that can add up
and we deal with it we you know deal
with it we throw in leap seconds
23 hours 56 minutes
and four seconds that's our rotation
rate
to the start they start it's exactly 24
hours on
average and that average is changing
right oh man that is that's so cool man
yeah just to show you that that smart
people think about this stuff
yeah and solve it so you don't have to
because everyone you just think
everything oh just it works
oh the computer tells me what the right
time is and everything and the bank
knows what time it is and my gps
we've got people thinking about this
stuff so before the atomic clock
nobody knew what time it was that's why
they synchronized clocks at the
beginning of heist movies
everyone had different time dude oh my
god that's crazy
oh man i wish i lived back there and i'd
never be late for anything
it'd be like chuck you're 10 minutes
late not according to my watch
and as far as i can tell
don't nobody know what time it is
i'm not 10 minutes late you 10 minutes
early that's what the problem is
so that's all i got to say and it's a
fascinating thing that is fascinating
and i love thinking about it just
because of
how many different branches of of
the science and technological world had
to come together to figure this out
sweet well i gotta go i'm i'm i'm
preparing for the next leap
second
so all right dude by the way if we have
a leap second announced we'll do a
special show
and maybe celebrate that and i'll bring
out my atomic clock and we can watch it
that'd be so cool i'm all about it okay
yes and make sure
don't forget the champagne because you
said you had champagne the last time
so don't even try to skip out on the
stream forget that that's right
okay i'm just saying
all right this is star talk the
explainer video
check good day oh it's a pleasure neil
degrasse tyson here
you